the more people know about what's going
on the angry they are about it hi I'm
Mike Griggs with Reason TV and I'm here
today with Radley Balko author of rise
of the warrior cop Bradley's also an
alumnus of Reason magazine and an
investigative reporter with the African
Post Bradley good to have you here today
thank for having me Mike so what is the
warrior cop where did it come from well
the warrior cop is basically this idea
the police have become more militarized
more soldier like in the last probably
generation or two and it applies you
know to the weapons that they're using
to the uniforms that they wear which
have switched from sort of the police
blues to these battle dress uniforms
which mimic military uniforms to the
tactics they use to you know what I
think is the most kind of pervasive
problem which is the mindset that police
officers take to the job and this has
been fostered by you know a number of
policies some of which you know didn't
necessarily intend this to be the
outcome but also just a lot of war and
sort of martial rhetoric from
politicians over the years that it's
also sort of nudged this Trent this
trend to where we are today so you put
the birthplace of the of the SWAT team
which is a big part of police
militarization Los Angeles the LAPD the
brainchild of Daryl gates who worked for
the LAPD and it was a response to the
Watts Riots in 1965 the Clocktower
shooting in Austin with Charles Whitman
and at the time you sort of you're not
you don't criticize gates for this
you're saying maybe it was sensible at
the time to say police as we knew them
in 1965 we're not actually prepared for
first situations of urban violence with
shooters and buildings and that kind of
thing so at what point would you say
that the SWAT team went from this idea
to be used like very selectively and
very certain very violent situations
when did it become this thing that was
normal to use wherever whenever so yes I
think there two trends that were going
on in the late 60s and early 70s one was
as you mentioned this rise of the SWAT
team that started in LA and and after
two really high-profile incidents one
with the Black Panthers and one with the
assembly assemblies Liberation Army that
were both of these raids were televised
got to swat a lot of publicity started
spreading to other cities and so you
know we go from one SWAT team the 19th
about 1970 to about 500 by 1975 but you
know throughout the 70s the SWAT teams
were used in these emergency type
situations so again you know riots and
hostage takings and bank robberies and
they were used in situations where the
government we using violence to defuse
an already violent situation right where
lives were at mediately at-risk at the
same time you have this other trend
which is Nixon's drug war so Nixon
declared war on drugs starts really kind
of amping up the battlefield rhetoric
with with respect to drugs he passes the
pushes the Nonaka raid through Congress
which it was actually the brainchild of
a 29 year old Senate aide you know
wasn't something that police chiefs were
demanding it wasn't something
criminologist were saying was necessary
this is a political ploy basically but
both of these trends are sort of moving
parallel into the 1980s and it's really
during the Reagan administration that we
see them converge and this is where we
start to see SWAT teams used for to
serve warrants on people suspected of
non-violent consensual drug crimes and
here now SWAT teams are actually
creating violence where there was none
before and this is where I think you
know the trend really starts to become
problematic we've got to a point where
we've gone from hostage situations armed
shooters this kind of stuff to police
creating violence where there was none
and it's largely because of Nixon
dehumanizing drug users drug dealers and
then things sort of there becomes a
moment where we pause and say wait a
minute is this a good idea
I mean what when does this happen so
well so Nixon declares war on drugs he
pushes through the no-knock raid bill
through Congress and what happens a
couple things happens that so Congress
passed two bills one that applied to
federal narcotics agents doing federal
investigations anywhere in the country
the other bill applied only to the DC
Police Department because Congress has
jurisdiction over DC so what was
fascinating is there two different
reactions in DC the police chief at the
time Jerry Wilson was a very kind of
forward-thinking police chief took a
very less reactionary approach to crime
and he actually refused to implement the
no no no NOC law he said it wasn't
necessary he said you know there was no
need to barge in
people's homes like this and you know
oddly enough crime actually went down in
DC over the next few years while it went
up in the rest of the country at the
federal level things are very different
you had these narcotics agents who made
full use of this law and they were you
know raiding homes left and right they
were raiding homes without warrants they
were you know terrorizing innocent
people but these weren't SWAT teams
these were narcotics cops and street
clothes basically undercover cops and
they were kicking down doors and what
happened was there were a few raids that
really started to pick up some national
attention and Congress actually so it
shows some remorse and shame they they
hold hearings they bring victims in to
testify and they actually end up
repealing both no-knock laws and not
only that they pass another law making
the federal government liable any time a
federal agent commits the raid on the
wrong house so it was this rare moment
where you know the drug war was still
sort of intractable or wasn't completely
intractable Congress could actually
admitted made a mistake and gone a
little bit too far and actually rein
things in a little bit that's
unfortunately pretty much the last time
that would happen so that's that's our
last bright spot and then that's not
even being cynical or hyperbolic I mean
I really between then and now that's the
last time anybody's gonna say maybe
let's slow down well I mean the Carter
Administration really kind of put a
brake on on all of this as well but then
unfortunately as Carter left office
there are a bunch of scandals where you
know it was rumored that his own drug
czar done cocaine at a normal party and
so the Reagan people come in and they
really kind of use the negative
publicity from the Carter Administration
sort of lacks attitude toward drugs to
really kind of fill all these positions
with moralists and you know people who
took a very kind of it's just about
right and wrong sort of approach to the
war on drugs and this is where we really
see the both the rhetoric and the policy
start to escalate now we see SWAT teams
raiding small friendly poker games
you've talked about there was I think
two years ago or a year and a half ago
the Department of Education was the SWAT
team to raid the home of a couple who'd
maybe used some sort of mail fraud to
get student loans they didn't need yeah
which obviously you know against the law
but is it does it require a SWAT team
and what happens that we go from SWAT
teams for drug houses
do raiding poker games of people's homes
to rating people who would maybe done
mail fraud or something they're a couple
I think they're a couple periods where
we kind of inter new ground in this
issue the first is in 1996 when
California legalized as medical
marijuana and you know up until that
point the justification for using these
kinds of heavy-handed tactics was always
that you know drug dealers are terrible
people they're dangerous or heavily
armed they're career criminals you know
they have wouldn't think twice before
taking out a cop and that you know a lot
of that wasn't true there are counter
arguments to all those points but at
least they were making the argument
right there they were saying we need
this amount of force because of this
threat we're facing is significant and
we need to protect you know officer
safety once California legalize medical
marijuana and the federal government now
starts sending SWAT teams and to raid
these dispensaries that justification
goes out the window right I mean these
are businesses that are openly operating
they have business licenses they're
operating in compliance with state law I
mean nobody's can seriously argue that
the you know hippie mom-and-pop couple
who run the pot dispensary our threat to
you know pull an ar-15 out from under
the counter and kill a bunch of federal
agents this was about sending a
political message these these people
were openly flouting federal law and so
we had to bring the boot down on them to
make an example of them and this is
really sort of terrifying territory that
we enter in the 1990s and of course it's
still going on today this is government
using violence to send a political
message and that's you know that's not
something we normally associate with
free societies the next sort of frontier
I think comes there wasn't sort of a
make-or-break moment when it happened
but I think in just in the last probably
seven or eight years we've really seen
SWAT mission creep grow beyond the drug
war and now you know as you said we're
seeing these raids on poker games
particular when the Texas Hold'em craze
started taking off in the mid 2000s we
saw SWAT teams breaking up poker
neighborhood poker games poker games at
bars that were openly advertised were
raided with SWAT teams you know reason
TV did the story about the the VFW hall
in Dallas that was raided by a SWAT team
because they were conducting charity
poker games and here's where we really
start to see the mission creep and SWAT
sort of looking for new reasons to use
the sort of force you know there's the
old saying when you have a Hammer Every
Problem looks like a nail and I think
in the last decade that's really where
we've seen this happen and now we're out
to the point where we're seeing SWAT way
trades for regulatory inspections it's
now become sort of an end-around the 4th
amendment there been lots of raids on
bars where you know it was basically
just a drug sweep but the police used
you know brought somebody from the
alcohol inspection board to come with
them and now it's you know officially an
alcohol inspection we're just making
sure your liquors clip properly labeled
but we're gonna go ahead and point our
guns at all your customers and search
them you're booked up until the very end
where you get to the sort of reform
section by the time you get to the
reform section actually even in the
beginning the reform section which is
about the story of Shay Calvo the mayor
of Rowan Heights and Maryland yeah you
feel hopeless yeah I feel like this is
intractable nevertheless you do have
some suggestions for reform you list you
know accountability transparency
changing police culture you know what
are the most important ones which ones
do you really because you know every
reformer has a wish list yeah and it
includes some some you know starry-eyed
stuff what's the stuff that you really
think would work well that's the problem
I mean the stuff that would be most
effective is the stuff that's least
likely to happen so yeah ending the drug
war you know raining SWAT in to only
serve warrants and these I mean if I
could write a rule and I'm not anti SWAT
team I do think there's an appropriate
use for them if I could write rule would
be that you know SWAT teams should only
be used when an act of violence is being
committed or about to be committed
actual violence right that would be a
great rule it's never gonna pass because
you know the sending SWAT teams out on
drug raids is financially it brings
revenue into police departments through
federal grants and asset forfeiture but
that would be a great rule but also I
mean you know part of it is just
building up the will for reform and you
know what I found and actually this is
you know encouraging in another wise
pretty cynical book the more people know
about what's going on the angry they are
about it and I talked about this raid in
Columbia Missouri that was recorded a
few years ago and posted online and you
know this was a very standard raid I
mean it was just like every other one of
these drug raids but it was you know
it's extraordinarily violent to shoot
the dog there's a you know kid in the
house I didn't know about you know they
come in shooting and screaming and you
know with all their guns and what was
amazing as it gets posted online and
they
action was just the videos viral
interaction was just outraged I mean
police department their phone lines are
shut down you know their email got shut
down because they were overwhelmed they
got death threats and it was almost as
if you know but it was actually like you
know the internet intergeneration for
the first time was seeing how the drug
war was actually fought on the ground
and they were very very angry by what
they saw and I think so I think you know
just transparency will do a lot I mean I
think if we can just get word out about
what's happening then I think we can
build up the will for some reform so I
think all these rates should be recorded
and those videos should be subject to
FOIA and open records requests well
Radley thank you for being here today
for talking about your book rise of the
warrior cop thanks Mike family on four
reason TV I'm Mike Rick